[Music]  deputy sheriff need of immediate  assistance does anybody read me  [Music]  i have an emergency i got a homicide  scene with two bodies and a third  missing person  [Music]  dad i was in the desert with ellie  yesterday  where was she exactly  are you okay  stop  nope  the playing with our product never  arrived  this is your problem now i will take  care of it  if we keep walking this way we are gonna  die  we are alone no one is ever gonna find  us here all right we're in the middle of  the desert  the monster  saw your truck driving in the distance  there's never anyone out here  dad what's going on i don't know bad  things  is someone there please help  we have to keep running  he's coming  [Music]  you